benvenuti storico
sono tornati i giochi paura ma molto
poco su questo gioco dovrebbe essere il
gioco più pauroso di robot si chiama
judy quindi avvertimento prima di
iniziare se vi fanno troppa paura i
giochi paurosi vi lascio qui ho qui il
link per vedere ai giochi o altri video
divertenti che non sono paurosi io no se
invece vi piacciono le cose paurose
sappiate che queste più pauroso del
solito e potrebbe impressionarvi un
pochettino perché questa giu si fa un
bel po di paura quindi più avvisato
lasciate un bel mi piace e mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn
[Musica]
eccoci qua allora come vi ho detto prima
questo gioco si chiama judy abbiamo un
capitolo 1 è un capitolo 2 hai lasciato
un biglietto se volete vedere altri
giochi super paurosi perché se questo
video di 10.000 vi piace ci saranno
altri giochi che possiamo ecco la guarda
c'è scritto giù di lì quella è
la testa di una donna una bambola perché
dobbiamo entrare dentro al suo palazzo
cartello con rigori correte pronte
questo è il capitolo 2 ma noi andiamo al
capitolo v qua uno no aspetta e no non
so se quali il capitolo 1 forse dobbiamo
andare dall'altra parte a fine ecco
capitolo trovato poi alla figlia il
video scriverti se secondo voi questo
gioco è più paurosa di aghi o aghi o
meno parole pauroso di aghi vaghi poppy
plate aykol di wood è quindi siamo in
america dobbiamo scoprire ancora tutta
la storia di questa judy che sapete che
in genere dietro a questi cattivi o
questi mostri c'è sempre una storia del
come sono di 20 i cattivi come sono
diventati mostri in genere anche la
parte più interessante per me quindi
forse judy era un'attrice e lei successo
qualcosa cosa qui e questa judy la
scritta sembra così allegra e derivati
capo che è così come la visuale così che
non riesce a guardarsi ok purtroppo la
visuale non è esterna che vediamo
personaggio ma siamo in prima persona
quindi sarà ancora più inquietante
vediamo esploriamo andiamo polemica con
le luci spente con le luci spente con
click del mouse bene meglio non
riusciamo possiamo questa è la casa di
judy e non potevi dire ma siamo solo noi
due acque dentro dove sono finiti gli
altri giochi
aiuto oltre su qualcosa vieni viene
posto viene al primo posto al primo
posto vi sono almeno mi fai compagnia ma
stiamo andando con questo trenino tipo
aspettando tipo i patti di divertimento
che ti fanno andare
nei due però sono così tanti giocatori
prima ho paura che ci sia qualche jobs
che è all'improvviso e se qualcosa che
ci fa spaventare quelle dovrebbe essere
giù dive di pegli la luce una camera che
la sta registrando e lei sta girando ho
chiesto cosa è successa questa judy
stiamo attenti a tutti i dettagli magari
si serviranno per vincere il gioco
caduto qualcosa lei non ho capito che
cos'era questi sembrano dei mostri
spegne la luce solo tipo di li spaventa
passeri tutto allagato qua ci sono dei
rami qua sopra il successo qualcosa di
strano
di laggiù ma è tipo una bambola o era un
un attrice
eccola a miss messe perfetta quindi a
pinto qualche concorso di bellezza o tre
è presidente restante si fa sempre più
interessante il mistero di judy qui non
si possono usare un armadio cos'è questo
se
non miriamo ok ok ora io sono i vecchi
sutra sta colorando a salire come non mi
esce sa dire come ok ok meno male ti
mostri avete non vi avrebbe fatto troppa
paura non sto preparando con ogni tipo
aspetta famiglie cerca casa se sud o giu
di un mostro di hollywood
cosa del che si è trasformata in
plastica what judy ha perso la sua
bellezza
la star di olivo judy sta invecchiando è
sta perdendo la sua bellezza
forse per questo che si è arrabbiata si
è trasformato in un mostro perché
rilevano queste cose di lei e lei si è
arrabbiata tantissimo
insieme e non lo so dobbiamo esplorare e
cercare qualche altro indizio sul
mistero di judy e c6 si sono qui ma ci
sono dei rami non credo non si può
passare da quello che sarà vero amore
ora la mia pila forse dove un po stare
qua
cosa c'è scritto qua giù di ha attaccato
un cameraman tre persone ferite due
morte quindi la sua rabbia è cresciuta
sempre di più fino ad amare il cameraman
e lì attaccati con un ferro da stiro che
nascondeva una lava ma è cattivissimo
allora come abbiamo visto prima lista di
nando la stavano filmando quindi forse
c'è una cosa connessa quello no da qua
non si può portare comunque super
interessante questo punto la di zoom
wolf adoro i giochi in cui c'è una bella
storia dietro con tanti misteri da
scoprire anche anche i quali era molto
interessante la storia dove dobbiamo
andare per le moto come questa no non
siamo passati però che non sia quello
che jones che che qui c'è un
interruttore la fa a premere non si può
fare ma andiamo a destra si sia scordato
che qui a sinistra che ci sono altri
tuoi giocatori proviamo a seguire
[Musica]
che governa un ragno e un ragno lo vedo
d'aspetto
allora dice c'è una cosa che dice se ti
nascondi dentro ai locker puoi salvarti
è arrivato nessun riscatto siamo
scappati poteva scappare il capo storico
fa
mattoni state proprio ordinato per tutto
a vedere cosa viene
dov'è finita allora noi siamo scappati
qui sono insieme agli altri due dove
se n'è andato
non visto l'ho visto ho visto mi sa che
devo mettere fuoco all'olio così almeno
potremo uscire da fuoco
devo prendere l'accendino e poi
lui e non la voglio rivedere troppo
brutta
bomba magante dove devo ammetterlo non
capisco qui c'è qualcosa qui c'è
l'accendino c'è scritto judy è sparita
ma nessuno l'ha cercata
forse questo l'olio per terra jona forse
bisogna andare da un'altra parte
spero che non arrivi di nuovo nei ma
[Musica]
mi sa che era proprio da questa parte
dove sarà quest'olio e qui mi ha visto
hai visto scampo scampo stato o ne ho
preso
o presso vitale ora
ecco un personaggio
ad orologio di nuovo di qua scappa
scappa scappa scappa catus capo che tu
non ha scopi dove ho trovato un
passaggio segreto una piccola porticina
a fassone allora ho trovato questo
passaggio segreto che è qui mi ha
portato bene ciao non era un
paio col nuovo la bruttissima
potuti stare
ma noi a noi va tornato da qui ecco
passiamo dal passaggio segreto forse
così riusciamo più velocemente a trovare
l'olio che vedo qualcuno
no mi ha preso di nuovo
aiuto vi aspetto qui c'è qualcosa e sono
finita forse l'ho trovato provato
trova l'uscita c'è scritto io sono
riuscito
altrimenti rimarremo bruciacchiati qua
dentro la sua attività con uscita
seguimi vita non lo so sono all'inizio
eccomi dove
grazie a su brigati corriamo corriamo
gli arrivi lei quindi dobbiamo andare di
qua prezzo adesso è chiusa non ho più
basta premere premetti
forse ce l'abbiamo fatta sia al basso
profumo qua c'è pronta già o di un
defribillatore del defibrillatore penale
è ribellata
aiuto
adesso
no non mi dire che parli proprio tu ti
presso troviamo una strada per scappare
prima che arrivi se dobbiamo trovare una
chiave aspetta forse ho trovato qualcosa
sì questo è un passaggio bravo o andiamo
a ecco dove devi premere contro uno con
ok ti abbassati che sei arrivato io ci
sono 6 giu di qua mi verrà un impasto ma
spero che non esca acqua aggiunti no ti
prego no no no quale parte dobbiamo
andare io vado dritto aspetto forse
usati segue stiamo finendo
cos'è la jazz qualcosa
il futuro di te farei farcita di brutto
la zucca laboratorio di perfezione da
questa parte come gli altri giocatori
hanno preso un'altra strada
aspetto qui c'è qualcosa lo vedi mi
spaventa la prima
sembra un mostro sembra tipo un
prototipo di judy però brutto ma forse
tornare indietro e pensa che qua non
possiamo passare forse dobbiamo tornare
indietro noi purtroppo se non prendere
un'altra strada dai sbrigati e dove
dovevamo girare qui e non vi stavate
così attaccato con quella accendino
preparare la scorreggia mettere tutto a
fuoco
però forse non dobbiamo passare dalla
parte di nuovo vabbè io odio il jump che
lo sapete io ho un no mi spavento tanti
possiamo veramente che dove sta andando
ma sei tu questo ma penso che per chiuso
e allora dove dobbiamo andare a che
proviamo su un'altra strada allora senti
questo rumore
no qua stiamo tornando indietro che
siamo tornati nella stanza iniziale se
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa perché sono
bloccate
oppure ora che è apparsa judy si è
sbloccata la strada di là che l'unico
modo è tornare dove eravamo prima anche
di altri giocatori sono andati lì per il
futuro che loro i compagni azzurri
perché a me viene un infarto ogni volta
cade a senso unico quindi
che cosa è successo
l'ho fatto arrivare qui
[Musica]
invece visti scappare da questo ok
era un drago con le forbici in mano
l'unico che peserà
si è fatto a pezzi la professione
non ho capito niente chi diceva che
eravamo nel studio del chirurgo ma c'è
quello trasformato giudice c'è una
storia qui qui uscita premiamo un'ora
dice di strisciare miller balza in modo
tale di trovare il pulsante per
accendere la luce stare attenti a non
farci vedere qua nell'erba alta ti sto
seguendo
arrivato si
notano a fianco la tenda sto cercando
l'entrata nella tenda non c'è niente
dentro l'azienda può cercare
l'elettricità da qualche altra parte
anche loro stanno cercando man mano
nell'erba alta cioè non si inchina
nostro ecco giovane non giulini sta sì
sì sono proprio qui a fianco della
macchina sta passando più con me che
paura ok hai eliminato giocatore io sono
proprio qui a fianco alla sua macchina
ecco mi chiamo giorno di fronte vite si
no
sono qua forse quale elettricità
laggiù in quel giochino è una specie di
ferrovia ceo giungato eno di un gatto a
forma di treno su tre non forma di kato
sì ma ancora non abbiamo trovato il
pulsante per l'elettricità sembra tv
luna park sì che è successo a judy dov'è
davanti a me c'è qualcosa che gira la
probabile in armi magari lì il pulsante
nel frattempo abbiamo perso un giocatore
che vorrei questi 3
poverino hai una giostra siamo tutti e
tre qui però non c'è il pulsante
dovessero a questo pulsante
ragioni felicia ora solo povero unità le
e adesso è rinchiuso da una parte da
dove non lo so sono pro fuori penso che
sono fuori dai giochi creati avviserà
aiuto
corriamo doppia votazione sono rimasti
solo noi due bisogna
però quasi sono per le scale aspetto
forse ho trovato qualcosa 7 ho visto una
fiamma qui bravo vai esplora controlla
io quando riesco a salire unti città con
le fiamme tutto un po abbandonato però
non tralascia il pulsante e questo era
il 3 alla forma di gatto che
sta passando gli aiuti mia pista forza
ritrovato una piatta uscita qui hai
trovato qualcosa bisogna angolato il
provato regioni hanno trovato qualcosa
ok ragazzi ho trovato finalmente la
abbiamo preso
6 credo
che io nel frattempo corro nuovamente
verso li sperando che non vive da joe
the e anche per non ascoltare l'erba
abbia visto lo stesso e nel frattempo
vitale provvederà ad accendere le luci
si sono quasi brava dove devo andare
allora io ho attivato il power supply
che sta qua dentro che dietro il bancone
e quello della recinzione se tu vai
infatti poi dietro il bancone troverai
un palo
beh almeno adesso ricomincio da qui
non mi ha detto io sono nella caverna
qua sotto dove la caverna così almeno
non mi seguiranno tre paesi
dove la caverna in parola dovrebbe
essere qui la caverna non dovrebbe
essere troppo lontana con la scuola non
buttiamoci speriamo che giochino entry
anche nella caverna non avere il solo
carta è un po buio è vero
e o anche
no ma l'hanno ritrovata
deve attivare questo allora questo rosso
è attivo lo
fa prova a supporto mentre
[Musica]
almeno no no no no io sono caduto da
qualche parte ciao bloccato dentro forno
no no io sono riuscito ad uscire ecco mi
sono fatta ci sei con le luci ancora
però
sono dietro di te sia scappiamo secondo
me tu ti arriverà anche qua dobbiamo
trovare qualcosa per aprire la porta
dice presto troviamo un attrezzo per
aprire la posta per pagare i giovedì 26
set ognuno va aggiornata fece una porta
aperta ma di grandissimo aiuto ha detto
c'è scritto di tenere le luci spente
perché altrimenti il mostro ragno
e sensibile una luce che mostra un anno
e sono a me i giudici
ma non si vede non c'ero io
saranno elia dal muro la vedo molto bene
forse è meglio andare via eccole
l'attrezzo pero prima portata ok
perché devi scivolare piano piano lo
vado a prendere i obama via fatti parte
ho avuta e questo gioco aspetto forse
non riesco a prendere no mi ha preso ok
allora riprovo io profonde trovano
mamma mia non lo voglio rivedere quel
mostro
attenta
piano
non ha funzionato forse dobbiamo trovare
un'altra soluzione allora allora ho
capito dice di spegnere tutte le luci
quindi salendo per le scale o spento
l'interruttore si sono spente le luci
che stavano vicino perché c'è l'immagine
di un interruttore qua esatto potevamo
spegnere i motori da trovare a prenderla
non so se ce la faccio mai spento tutto
si hanno non cedere pazzini
non presenta quindi bisogna bisognava
semplicemente
sì e io adesso non so se riesco a
scendere si sono fatti per come stavamo
bene quindi adesso dobbiamo entrare
dall'altra porta giusto ci stiamo quasi
trova l'uscita
sono dietro di lei possiamo farcela qui
che cosa c'è c'è un interruttore
dice che c'è un altro ragno non lo so ho
sentito dei rumori però è
mamma mia che i rumori strani
archivi di judy personale
forse qua la mia felicità
aquarium construction no dovete vietato
nel 1972 tutto che sia andata negli
archivi si sta cercando una via d'uscita
ripeto sono dietro di
lei e lei e lei e lei stai andando
indietro sono ferma qua perché lei non
entra nel tunnel ok forse la via
d'uscita è proprio quella che si sia
tolta a lei andava via ok andiamo
sono dietro di te
devi fare è prendere un colpo che inizia
a gridare all'improvviso lo sai che io
mi spavento
forse siamo sulla strada giusta dice
attento
non mi sembrava tanto giusta come strada
ma per fortuna non ci ha preso o no ma
pensavo che avesse preso ma dov'è la mia
pena non vedo questi libri sono
principalmente sui rom sulla robotica ok
sono qua dietro di te mi vedi che ti si
non capisco dove devo andare
guarda io qua sotto un martello ok ora
che abbiamo preso il martello possiamo
proseguire da un'altra parte
[Musica]
dove stiamo andando non solo proviamo ad
esplorare no qui scaricando indietro
troviamo qua siamo vedere qui che c'è
niente di che allora il
il team farc electric
quindi forse qui possiamo questa
macchina non partirà il legno è
ricoperto di sangue
giudico in fase veramente che io mi
abbasserei pelati e tra c'è qualcosa
vediamo che c'è qualcosa però non può
andare non fa andare là quindi forse non
dobbiamo andare là e sentiamo il
martello quest'opera mettiamo sul
computer no e allora dobbiamo andare via
d'acqua sento che si stava avvicinando
un abbiamo esplorato tutto vero penso
che allora andiamo andiamo dalla parte
dove c'è scritto acquario
ok che cosa si fa un acquario nel mondo
come se non bastasse ora di tempo
rapidi che c'è qualcosa là sopra
che cos'è un altro robot
credo proprio di sì tu no reno via
d'uscita ma qui è cambiato tutto non era
più non era così prima quando siamo
arrivati e sono riusciti a salire posso
profondamente fare un passaggio qua da
sopra si che mi sono arrampicato acqua
guarda c'è un passaggio qua dietro
sbrigati
abbiamo trovato qua
wow
partiamo mai chiuso
di punta all'altra eccolo l'acquario non
è acquario gestito a cui un e che cosa
era pure umano e proviamo per martello
bravissima
resta sbrigativo che sono qui dietro i
the
best
se judy che si è trasformata in un robot
millepiedi lupo o no è bruttissima dice
che dobbiamo attaccarla col martello col
martello o pistola
non so se la sta colpendo di più
come infatti un lato resto non ha preso
e dove aiutarti
no mi ha preso di nuovo ex set dal quale
se si vuole ok hanno fatto abbiamo
sconfitta dice che ora l'uscita è
accessibile dove è uscito dobbiamo
vedere attenta perché lei è ancora viva
la dietro
scomparsa forse questa la porta abbiamo
più si privi
ciao thomas pregio abbiamo finito il
capitolo nino però non è stato molto
pauroso ma anche molto avvincente ma
voglio ancora scoprire colette greto di
judy se volete facciamo anche il
capitolo 2 lasciato un di più lacerato e
scrivetecelo nei commenti ora vi
lasciamo qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere inoltre altri video uncut e
su quella che preferite buona visione
[Musica]